Gwen Stefani talks future marriage plans  and whether we could ever see a no doubt  reunion the 46 year old singer stopped  by Ryan Seacrest Morning Show on Friday  and when asked if she would consider  marriage again the fani got a bit  tongue-tied  I don't know god I don't I don't know  any of those everything going so quickly  I just aren't I'm in the moment the  singer called it quits with Gavin  Rossdale in 2015 after nearly 13 years  of marriage and since then has been  pretty open about her whirlwind romance  with fellow voice coach Blake Shelton  bonny is nearing the end of her this is  what the truth feels like tor but would  she ever consider a reunion tour with no  doubt you never know what's gonna happen  right look at my life it may be crazy  but the mom of two is in a great place  she told Seacrest I feel so awake I feel  so alive and so grateful